وقد تعهد الرئيس الاوكراني
بمواصله اعداد قوه الدفاع والامن
الاوكراني للعام المقبل من سنه الجديده
ستكون حاسمه في ما يخص المعارك الميدانيه
في اوكرانيا للعام المقبل يؤكد ان السنه
الجديده ستكون حاسمه في ما يخص المعارك
نتفهم المخاطر في الشتاء ونتفاهم ما يتعين
علينا القيام به في الربيع وبالتالي نفهم
النتائج التي يجب ان يظهرها قطاع الدفاع
والامن باكمله وقد تمت مناقشه التوريد
الذخيره واصلاح المعدات العسكريه بشكل
منفصل
الجزيره
سنه جديده يقول بانها ستكون حاسمه ماذا في
تفاصيل تامر
امسدار بالفعل الرئيس زينسكي طيله الثلاثه
ايام الماضيه وهو يتحدث عن القتال عن
القتال عن استمرار القتال عن استمرار
العمليات واستعاده مزيد من المناطق وتقدم
للقوات الاوكرانيه لا يتحدث ابدا عن مساله
المفاوضات عن مساله اييه اي محادثات او اي
قمه لسلام محتمل كما اشار الى ذلك وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني هو بالفعل يتحدث عن
عام حاسم يقول بان العام المقبل سوف يكون
حاسما من ناحيه المعارك على الارض بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه ويتحدث ايضا
عن اسبوع حاسم وهو الاسبوع المقبل من
ناحيه الحراك الدبلوماسي السياسي الذي
تعمل عليك كيا من اجل تحصيل مزيد من
المساعدات العسكريه والامدادات هو يقول
بانه ايه تم بالفعل يوم امس في اجتماع
اجتماع مع قاده الجيش الاوكراني بحث مزيد
من توريد الاسلحه والعمل على صيانه
الاسلحه التي تضررت سواء المعدات العسكريه
التي تضررت نتيجه استمرار معارك على اكثر
من جبهه في الجنوب والشرق و يتحدث ايضا عن
حرصي وانه يعمل بكل ما يمكنه من طاقه
للاسراء في الحصول على المساعدات العسكريه
التي تعاهدت الولايات المتحده بها هو
يراهن على هذه المساعدات ويقول بانها سوف
تغير من حده المعارك بشكل اكبر وسوف تحقق
مزيدا من التقدم للقوات الاخرانيه ايضا هو
يجدد تاكيد تاكيده على ما يتعلق بايه فرض
السياده الاوكرانيه على كامل الاراضي همم
التي همم بحوزه ما زالت بحوزه القوات
الروسيه يقول الهدف الرئيسي للعام المقبل
هو استعاده كامل الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه والحديث عن الدمباس
والحديث عن المناطق التي مازالت في سيطره
او عند سيطره القوات الروسيه في جنوب
البلاد لا سيما في بعض مناطق هيرسون في
زباروجا وهذه في الحقيقه النقطه التي يشير
اليها كانت كان العديد من المسؤولين
السياسيين بالامس ذهبوا الى ابعد من ذلك
همم مؤكدين بان اي مفاوضات بان اي سلام قد
يكون في المستقبل بين الجانب الروسي
والاكراني يجب ان يتضمن ما هو ابعد وهو
استعاده شبه جزيره القرم- وضمها الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من جديد اذا الشروط
كثيره وايضا الطلبات اكثر الحديث عن همم
اي جلسه اي اجتماع اي لقاء بين الجانب
الروسي والاوكراني في المستقبل يجب ان
يتضمن اعتراف من قبل قوات الروسيه بضروره
وقف قصف البنيه التحتيه للعاصمه كليفلي
العديد من المقاطعات التي تتعرض لقصف
متواصل بالاضافه الى رفع الحصار الكامل عن
الموانئ النهريه والبحريه وصولا الى سحب
القوات الروسيه المتواجده في محطه زبروشه
للطاقه النوويه وفي محيطها وفي الحقيقه
ازدهار هذا ما اشار اليه وزير الطاقه
الاوكرانيه يوم امس خلال لقائه بعدد من
السفراء الغربيين قال بان الحل واضح فيما
يتعلق في محطه الطاقه النوويه في جبروجيه
واتاكد بان هنالك محادثات وان الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه تعمل على ذلك بشكل
واضح من اجل سحب من اجل ايجاد منطقه
رماديه كما سماها في محيط المحطه وقال بان
الحل هو سحب كامل القوات الروسيه من هناك
نعم هذا بالنسبه اللي اوكرانيا همم رانيا
بالنسبه للجانب الروسي الرئيسي همم
فلاديمير بوتين اعلن عن فرض حظر على تصدير
النفط الروسي ومشتقاته لي الذين حددوا
سقفا لسعر هذا ما الذي تسعى روسيا لتحقيقه
من خلال ذلك
في الاونه الاخيره وعبرت عن رفضها الكامل
لاي تسعير همم ضفتها ومنتجاتها النفطيه
سواء على لسان وزاره الطاقه ووزاره همم
الخارجيه الكريم وحتى الرئيس الروسي
الفاضيه من الفوت ان الذي تحدث كثيرا
روسيا ترفض ذلك رفضا كاملا وعشيه همم
الاعلان عن الخطوات الرديه لروسيا على وضع
سعر
النفط الروسيه كان الكرملين قد اشار لانه
موسكو بالنسبه لموسكو هذه المساله هي
مساله مبدا وان ماسك ترفضه بشكل كامل ما
سميته به تشويه وتدبير عمليه التسويق
عمليه التسعير في اسواق الطاقه اشاره
الكريم الى ان السقف الذي وضعته بعض الدول
الاوروبيه لسعر يعني سعر مرتفع حسب تعبيره
لكنه اشار في الوقت نفسه انه في حال وافقت
روسيا الان على ذلك فهذا يعني انها ستطر
في المستقبل للموافقه على قد لا تصب في
صالحها في صالحه امنها القومي وما الى ذلك
وعليه فان هذه الخطوه كانت متوقعه وفقا لي
القرار الروسي روسي لن تقوم ببيع النفط
ومنتجاتها النفطيه لاي دوله تضع سقفا لسعر
النفط الروسي ومنتجاته فضلا عن ذلك ايضا
يحضر هذا المرسوم الذي وقعه امس الرئيس
الروسي في وادي ميرفت بما في ذلك بيع
النفط لتلك المستثمرين والمشتريين الاجانب
الذين تضم عقودهم عقودهم مساله وضع سقف لي
اسعار النفط الروسي ولكن من جهه اخرى يلفت
الانتباه نقطه في غايه الاهميه في هذا
المكتوب وهو ان الرئيس الروسي القديم يملك
الحق او يجوز له بتوريد بقرار منها قرار
خاص من الرئيس الروسي القديم بتوريد النفط
للدول التي فرضت سقفا لاسعار النفط روسيه
على ما يبدو هذه النقطه همم تم ادراجها في
المرسوم والقرار الروسي في مح من روسيا
على ما يبدو عثمان للمناوره لاسامه مع تلك
الدول التي باتت موسكوتا تصفها بغير
الصديقه فيما يتعلق بالنفط والغاز والوضع
السياسي شكرا لك رانيا موسكو شكرا ايضا
لتامر الصمادي كان معنا من قياس